I'm a capitalist right I believe in free
enterprise the opportunity to own and
run a business America capitalism lower
taxes on people all that stuff but what
I found out about the the minorities is
now they're waking up in America
and I don't mean woke they didn't go
that they went they went right they're
like wait a minute you didn't do
anything for us you conned us and they
voted on their emotions like women do
and now they're like wait a minute
America's in the in the we're we're in
bad shape I mean all the countries are
moving away from our dollar right so now
what I said they have left is they have
the the alphabet kids left
lgtbq right trans queer gays and then
they have the feminists that's all they
have left for the vote so it's
interesting you said that because I find
that and I talked to a lot of um
successful black people successful
Hispanics and I asked them I said why
did you think Trump was bad but they all
ended up coming to the same point that
said they were going off their emotions